اعلنت كل من اوكرانيا وبولندا وليتوانيا
انشاء ما سمته الدول الثلاث ممرا اخضر
لنقل الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى ميناء
كلايبيدا غربي ليتوانيا وقالت وزاره
الزراعه الاوكرانيه ان الاتفاق يقضي بنقل
شاحنات الحبوب الاوكرانيه الموجوده حاليا
على حدود بولندا الى الميناء خلال اليومين
المقبلين وكانت بولندا قد عارضت في وقت
سابق نقل الحبوب عبر اراضيها وذلك بسبب
تاثير هذه الصادرات على منتجاتها المحليه
وفق قولها وهددت اوكرانيا في وقت سابق من
الاسبوع الماضي بنقل المساله الى منظمه
التجاره
العالميه ينضم الينا من وارسو مراسل
الجزيره عبد الله الشامي عبد الله هنالك
اجتماعات تعقد في وارسو لمتابعه الاوضاع
في اوكرانيا ابرز هذه الاجتماعات وماذا
على جدول الاعمال وما جديد ما يتعلق
بالمساعدات
لاوكرانيا نعم ربما ابدا من الخبر الخاص
باتفاقيه نقل الصادرات الغذائيه
الاوكرانيه الى ليتوانيا عبر الاراضي
البولنديه هذا الامر كانت له علاقه ب منع
للتصدير كان مقرر من قبل دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي للثلاث اشهر الماض اي من شهر
يوليو حتى نهايه سبتمبر لكن بولندا بشكل
احادي قررت ان تمد هذا الحظر لقولها ان
الصادرات الاوكرانيه تؤثر على الاسواق
المحليه هنا وكذلك ايضا على الاسعار
وبالتالي كانت هناك هذه يعني هذا الاحتداد
بين البلدين الذي وصل كما قلت في الخبر
الى التهديد برفع قضيه من قبل اوكرانيا
على بولندا لكن الاتفاق الذي عقد اليوم
والذي يبدا تطبيقه من الغد يقضي ب يتم نقل
هذه الشاحنات لمسافه زيد على 900 م من
الحدود مع بولندا الى ليتوانيا التي لا
تشترك في حدود مع اوكرانيا ومن هناك في
ميناء كلبيدا غرب اوكرانيا غرب ليتوانيا
عفوا يتم نقلها الى دول اخرى خارج القاره
الاوروبيه في هذه الاثناء ايضا هنا في
وارسو ينعقد مؤتمر وارسو للامن الذي يعقد
هذه السنه في نسختها العاشره للحديث حول
اوكرانيا ايضا وكيفيه وضعها في حاله تمنع
كما قال القائد الاعلى للج العسكريه للنيو
تمنع حدوث هجوم ثالث مستقبلي تجاهها من
قبل روسيا وقال ايضا ان ما حدث في
اوكرانيا ادى الى ان تقوم دول الحلف بوضع
استراتيجيات رضع اكثر قوه ومتانه وان
المجموعات القتاليه المتواجده على الجبهه
الشرقيه كما تسمى اي الدول ذات الحدود مع
روسيا يتم حاليا زيادتها من اربع مجموعات
متواجده بالفعل هنا في بولندا ودول
البلطيق الثلاث الى دول اخرى مثل رومانيا
وبلغاريا التي هي ايضا مشتركه في حدود مع
روسيا هناك حديث ايضا في ذات السياق حول
كيفيه التجاوز لعالم ما بعد هذه الحرب
حديث حول كيفيه حمايه البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه في اوروبا وفي مناطق اخرى تسمى
بدول الحلفاء اي الدول المشتركه معها في
ذات الافكار والاهداف ينتظر من هذا
المؤتمر الذي ينتهي مساء الغد ان تكون
هناك توصيات تقدم لوزراء دفاع النيتو
الذين يجتمعون نهايه الاسبوع المقبل في
بروكسل وكذلك ايضا للقاده الاوروبيين
الذين يجتمعون بعد يومين من الان في
اسبانيا لمناقشه رفع مستوى الدعم
لاوكرانيا لكن كانت هناك احاديث واضحه هذا
اليوم في الجلسات الصباحيه حول حاجه
اوكرانيا الى اكثر من مجرد الوعود واكثر
من مجرد الاماني لان المخزون المتواجد لدى
القوات الاوكرانيه بالفعل والذي تم تسليمه
من قبل الولايات المتحده ودول النيتو
لازال حتى اللحظه يعني لا يفي بالغرض ولا
يمكن لاوكرانيا من خلاله كما قالت نائبه
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ان تفي بما تريد
من خلال تحرير اراضيها كامله كما قالت في
احدى الجلسات الصباحيه هذا اليوم في وارسو
شكرا لك من وارسو مراس الجزيره عبد الله
الشامي